Coco is Pixar's latest animated film and
this one tells the story of young Miguel
a boy who really wants to be a musician
he looks up to arnesto dela Cruz the
most famous musician he knows of he has
a special attic hideaway dedicated to
this musician where he watches old VHS
tapes of dela Cruz's performances he
wants so much to be a musician like him
one day but his family would prefer that
he makes shoes for a living because
that's what all of his relatives have
done music is pretty much banned in his
family so one day he decides to steal or
nesto dela Cruz his guitar from his
grave and in so doing finds himself in
the land of the dead there he must try
to find his passed away relatives to try
to connect with them and figure out why
exactly music is viewed as a curse on
his family and see if there's any way
that he can do what he wants to do with
his life while still pleasing his family
I stayed away from most marketing
materials with this film I had seen the
first teaser I think at a movie I was
forced to watch it and I didn't really
know anything about the film so it was
really nice to watch it unfold and see
this adventure blossom and be really
surprised consistently by a very moving
and touching film Pixar is really known
for making you cry and I would say for
myself for the majority of the movie I
was just enjoying the experience the
final 10 minutes though I heard people
crying all around me in the theater I
heard people blowing their noses
everyone was just really affected by the
last 10 minutes of this movie and it's
because it takes its time to build up a
credible story with a family and a
backstory and real history and actual
pathos like you feel like you are
stepping into a big story that's already
happened and few films are able to
accomplish that especially animated
films a film that feels like it has
history like it happened before the
movie started like these characters
existed in this world before the film
began and that's one of the best things
about Coco the music is also wonderful
the guitar work the singing it all
sounds really beautiful these are things
you've come to expect with Pixar it's a
cliche for me to say this movie is
gorgeously animated
it is it's insanely detailed and there
were specific shots of city structure
and streets and the cobblestone walkways
that just looked photorealistic and if
someone were to tell me they actually
are photorealistic and they just
inserted animated characters into this
architecture I'd be like that makes
sense because that's the level that
Pixar is at now computer animation has
come so far it's mind-boggling now there
was a film that came out in 2014 called
the book of life this film had similar
themes we had a young character whose
family wanted him to be a bullfighter
and he had a passion for it and he was
good at it but he also had other things
that he wanted to do with his life and
he wasn't sure the path he wanted to
take and it was kind of about him
bouncing what he wanted to do with his
life and love and it also revolved
around the Day of the Dead celebration
and so some people have said hey Pixar
you're ripping off the book of life
having actually seen both of the films I
can say that the stories are fairly
different and I wouldn't say any ripping
off or copying has occurred it's just
that they have similar themes and they
both take place during the Day of the
Dead celebration and so inevitably they
will be compared they've also come out
in a fairly short time span I feel like
if you love the book of life it's gonna
be really hard to not think about that
movie while watching Coco if you were
disappointed in that film though Coco
might be that one where you go okay
there they got some things right
this film is thematically rich it has a
lot of good surprises as well from a
story standpoint it has characters that
I can see people especially young kids
really appreciating it is however a
little familiar in its storytelling
basically because it's another story
about a young kid who wants to do
something with his life and his family
wants them to do something else and he
has to find it within him to appreciate
both sides and it's a good message for
kids but it did feel strikingly familiar
at times especially since the book of
life came out three years ago that's
really my biggest issue with Coco is
that as a story it's really beautiful
and very touching but it didn't really
wrap me into it and I didn't feel all
that invested in the characters despite
the fact that it's so well told and
really beautifully directed it doesn't
have as investing a story as I
would have liked because it does feel
like other things we've seen before but
still this is a good movie and it's well
done and the music and the animation and
the voice work is all really good I'm
gonna give Koko a B+ I hope you guys
check this one out if you are looking
forward to it it's definitely worth your
time it just is a little familiar and
it's storytelling we've seen these types
of themes before beyond that it's it's
definitely worth checking out and I
would see it in theaters guys thank you
so much as always for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]